each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon my name is lady Morgana
from Peru and my word is in the
University pero Anika Tanner area is
typical in the science and medicine II i
am described over war well Peru has
experienced assistance substantial
growth and prevailing in this
telecommunication market over last 10
years the Peruvian health system is a
split between public and private but is
very important the population and
cultural with restrict access to health
service twenty eight twenty percent the
population has access to private service
in Peru the name is a salud a 65-percent
approximately a access public service el
ministerio de salud and twenty-five
percent of the population has not access
to health care it's in general for the
rural population the Peruvian health
informatics systems is fragments and not
in a integrate because the private and
public is very very fragmented is not a
is not priority in the government Peru
is an onion country with poverty
concentrated in rural areas the total
population the last year was 29 millions
the population is multicultural
multi-ethnic the main spoke is pain is
Spanish and significant number of
Peruvian speak quechua and Amara we have
approximately a 25 region in the region
in highland and jungle the people are
speaking a Amara and Quechua
over our group work is a specific
specifically to while the capacity of
service providing organizatio particular
in area in rural and urban areas
facility facility best practice shed
sharing and collaboration using ICT with
organization and private and publix
what's the our objectives in this war
more 15 years ago to improve the working
conditions of sanitary personal the
telecommunication infrastructure of care
establishments officiality does without
telephone lines and service is absent to
provide health information service they
access hell information and access to
the stencil art course is very important
to share acknowledged with a population
community school and university access
to consultation with the spiracle
personal is more easy more flexible for
this a result in epidemiology system and
is very important in in the end a radio
a crate contents and software
development because we have remember in
the presentation in the in the morning
about the climatic change we have with a
change the climate II a6 infection
disease dengue malaria HIV a beluga
another infection because with a chase
climatic is more case with the patient
in highland and a jungle this is a map
in Peru we have three regions cause
highland and jungle our preoccupation is
highland and jungle then we have a 36
native mother tangle spoke in peru is
very difficult with a communication in
highland and jungle because the people
are not speaking Spanish
well a they very very important in over
an Iridium a we have pneumonia
tuberculosis trol malaria dengue HIV
shock albertoni losses anthrax is the
scenario is similar in bolivia brazil
argentina argentina colombia exeter etc
for example dinnae ammonia deposition in
the area rural is the dead is very very
important for the children the
tuberculosis the patient HIV they fierce
em the field he sees note that for HIV
they fear this is the patient is the red
is tuberculosis because for the
nutrition for the salary etc malaria is
we have more case because for the change
a climatic a similar in dengue in
Bolivia is similar in general in Peru
this is the situation in rural area
because the people the nutrition is bad
day a problemas dental is very very bad
and alpha Betty's is a very bad in no
education only the children and the
people working and working every day but
in the community the global proportion
is to die today training her won't
engage in hell and the life expectancy
is inflation disease are not a war
David's killer of children and young
adults we have 28 220 million in art in
america living in poverty 95 million are
indigenous people and they represent 40
45 43 point a four percent on the
population this is the sources the whom
this isn't a jungle in Peru because the
people decides is in building
billing a the people living a over river
is very common the infections in dengue
and malaria the people are very very
poor the salaries no more day one
hundred dollars so one can there in
jungle in in Peru okay the particular
needs our language culture inability to
pay to obtain access to internet because
is we have the mountains mountain is
very difficult why delete very very
expensive and why a griffey at a similar
situation local economy and life
schedule is is very difficult
geographical location is no excessively
access to alternativa providers for
example in Peru we have telefonica claro
nextel claro is Clarent and Telefonica
is only business to be done no not
rejection or not investigation in the
community university schools this is the
other map with these colors is about the
people speaking Quechua another tangled
mother's vaca valley kikuchiyo ivanka
cusco etc what a community effects they
having they have not families family
resides with the use of active internet
the first money second education field a
health the medical team should become
more involved and familiar a familiar
sight with activities of the community
the situation the miracle with the
rotation the rotation in the rural areas
is only two or three months no more
after the miracle return the by the city
the community is absent for the for this
a
health care in the community because all
the many miracles in Peru is only the
rotation similar in different sites in
the area jungle and kyla if because for
the situation is very important in this
patient because a we having not for
example one patient have tuberculosis
very difficult to to go in the city
because the tie is two or three days for
the doctors or or experts in de Lima or
on the other consult the access to them
is getting expensive especially in
remote area dandiya in the ad andean
highlands for example wireless we feel
is very important in this situation we
have using a telemedicine for the
reduced reducing the cost for the this
community in this a these departments
the other situation we have a 33 a
thousand public calvings or telecentres
in all Peru because the ante this public
are is having no the information having
no the context in the hell in the
education and other information for the
shared acknowledged for the community
for the population only is business to
business no more with respect the result
results is its indispensably to generate
the basis for the establishment of
strategic alliances between government
institution and participant organization
of the civil society to the
collaboration in concrete age actions
for general knowledge of ICT because the
government is absent institution public
d
in other role and institution public in
order is very different to connect and
create a network in general what do we
need to improve to take measures to
combat deficiencies in the delivery of
health service to low productivity low
quality and increase service to fight
against poverty this is uh this is not a
high priority education hell in the
government it's a mass it's very very
immersed in the population we have in
the area and in the rural area two
centers he'll post op waste of the
solute or health center he'll pose is in
the city and health center is in the
area really help us the personal with
leader leader from Asia and lack
communication telephone and Internet
only hours two or three hours no more
information dr. reference to make
consultation to send monitor is more
easy is more flexible to have more a
connectivity is there is not access to
electricity ignores or rural population
normal me normally the communication and
exchange of information are made by
displacement or hell personal between
establishments by working or by
employing the resident of fluid very
close with can take hours and even days
this is a picture in the postal saloon
and center health look the mountains
have no electricity no whether they work
in the personal working is
three or four hours no more because the
patient is have a for example have
accident in the afternoon the doctor is
not in this community the morally the
patient is dead this is the situation in
the jungle or in a specialist in
especial in jungle because the the
patient or health workers and working on
in the on the river on the carnival in
necessary hvar hell worker with computer
it's very important for the condition
and a consult expert medical in the city
this is a a jogger in a capacitation in
HIV in HIV and STD in Cuzco
approximately 40 thousand met in the
area rural either jeong eh she is a
leader because it the comments her is it
not necessary it not a nose a computer
is very important doctor and computer
with information for education and
prevention in this disease chains
acknowledged and skilled of participate
organization and individuals access to
information information al in resource
quality of service delivery creates
developments so we're poor for the
gnostic rapid innovation disease for
example we need grace developments
software in new money tuberculosis dr
oils malaria dengue chive each agadir
Tone Loc an track for the prevention and
education for dia for detriment 1406
more more rapid morphus
there is a significant combination on
problems in peru in peru jungle
highlands multiple language poverty or
health very limited infrastructure the
indigenous population is the poorest
with 43 person of the population living
in the poets were the opportunities more
responsibility from the government safe
communities provided for the population
innovation research resource human
institutional finance funds
informational aspect of ekiti table
access of tow decision-making and
governance with new ICT the participants
do not see each other physical nor do
they touch each other the role
telemedicine telling me tell
telemedicine is very important in these
areas reduce the cost owes for the
patient and they reduce the cost for the
miracles this is an example this is the
project with the phones a government
Asturias in espana and cover megan
students espania and a global knowledge
in malaysia with the phones we create a
plataforma technology in capacity
prevention in HIV in ICT is about
because in the red in the andean region
we have more younger more people affect
the day they all the way in this year we
have many person infected with HIV what
the other a botanist step in in my
institution the next step is very
important for the capacity to share
acknowledged d plataforma is using
elearning on distance
understand in any in any moment in any
place using the tab in publix the
computer in house the in the war etc etc
because we have with this plataform we
train 14 letters in the andean region
with HIV and STD each leader is training
in the community in the school in the
university and an other other population
all jer not necessary only a day in day
HIV is all it's always in the other
project is a we have in peru with a mini
stereo ministerio de Lucas ian pelli pro
yet a One Laptop Per chill one laptop
per chill only games only a video camera
mike rizzo stay and war and other guys
for the for the children because we have
the other support in 11 a one laptop per
chill d project this project we
integrate in way one laptop urchin
because the children interactive with a
with the partners with a brothers with
their sister with the other pop with the
other person of the population is very
important because we need to create more
tools about the education in the
prevention about the health care this
project is a gang in deja daire a 2010
is very the situation for the
communication for the prevention
in the area rural is very impor very
important fierce we training for the
hell work he'll work after the hell War
II to communicate a daughter is
different in dem communic communicate in
the city fierce we we saw I inflation we
we go to the doctor but the area rude
alley diferente de he'll work it this a
role player very very important the
community the other projects keepo them
the walls is development a program and
trainee he fell informatik for an Lea
reggio to participate investigates
investigation i integrate and Ned world
the investigation indian dr rachel for
example we have the hell informatics
data management only only project the
project half day the big vision after
day because this project to be continued
is not possible because he is the
problem with it we need to a training
with more community more / more persons
in in the hell informatica en la
diversidad pero en aquella tanner area /
here by example data Melanie's is
prevent with a nombre is about a you see
mobile I for de traitement impatient HIV
remember detriment I remembered a day
consult equis day dr. a lego public
electronic is only investigation because
we have the pro ye how many patient a
year in these ten years in HIV oh okay
we have the electronic dipen in de onde
a survey survey and a pro yi de oder a
pro yes rural telemedicine es Biko's
entice pro ye na na 2020
five is it no continue this project
because it's this is in standby no no
more participate in the community
information for the help professional
that a mini genomic sequence analyze
innovation disease in using real
molecular bio lobby a vaccine diagnostic
imaging analysis mods in TV say malaria
and computer a computer nilambur
jollibee by Joe Lobeck computer Nelly
being well this is the other projects
about the investigation informatik be
America now in the beginning the project
mobile I about the only for the
treatment boat but his restraints for
the patient and a medical doctors using
mobile I and Padilla and the other is
Nate laughs Nate love is a four day
resulta results about the ELISA and
wester blood only HIV we have the in the
next project is in dengue malaria and
anthrax and dense am influence h'huu no
Indian proposal it's Barry went to have
public Pollitz an aggressive actions is
very important they have the public
policies a it more using the access of
the ICT it is a CL to try to confirm
human network with the support of ICT in
the interaction and population with cool
who 40 the new generation we call
provides access to health service for
consumers in the urban and rural areas
is very important more capacitation for
the hell personal in WM country in non
necessary not necessary in only Peru is
very important in and
in Reggio gondia appropriate low-cost
technologies and the other alternative
is a free source and the bees and the
difference work is very with the license
microsoft in the university we call
support the delivery of health service
when the participants are in different
location is necessary training in disc
in those community communities in
Spanish language collaboration and
conclusion week cool collaborate with
our needed needs our experience and
continuing continued of the project is
very urgent need for funding to support
research and developments in this area
by public and private agents our dreams
is all community communicates the
hospital posto Desilu health centers all
the people in region and the onion for
education in the hell this is the
website instituto Messina tropicalis the
goal is to contribute with its efforts
to the solution of national problems
especially in infection disease de la
universidad peruana cali tanner area we
have more publication about ICT this the
book the last year the with 40 45
outdoors in the table have four files
science and technology education
government and health thank you very
much for your attention
the government is not high priority in
the agents this were is the private
institutions in this moment but I think
they were probably the proud the next in
government is very difficult because
they providers come because telefonica
uncle are not important it's only
business to business no more um in the
agent of Peruvian no no no no it's not
possible know if this is for for the
founts indifference we we have
differents found in in other country
because in na eh if they didn't we
present the project from the is possible
is positive or negative when we present
this project but we need a presenter
destroyed in ministerio salut on the
government oh the OC tell is very
difficult only the fiercest telefonica
hospital is is not for the power for the
private institution because the private
institution have a money
no this well a proper chill is a test of
the weather is not the problem because
the children's have a big problem
because all the day the children working
and working with the father's with a
mother in the rural area with a purchase
now the children are come under doors of
the school because they is fantastic now
the children the study and training and
check the email answers they they did
for example imagius movies but the
system have the filter for the four no
pornography no but it's very important I
think is a project for it not necessary
negroponte no necessary Intel in general
it is opportunity for the children
which is what is the cellular coverage
you obviously have very serious
geographical barriers we have very
serious language barriers 36 data that's
that's huge in a single country but I'm
curious because the statistic that's
given for mobile phone helping you
showed a mobile phone application is you
know what is the percentage of
population that really has cell phone
access and then a secondary question
that is if you're pushing training is it
raining too or these trainings oh well
for example in indie project with a
training HIV and STD is public and
private no it is very important for
because they the people is necessary
nola wish yeah okay the training is
presencia and training is neutral and
those into options to option we over a
workgroup is go to travel for example
cusco wonka velika yeah kucho the next
week we go to travel to Iquitos because
we need training for indigenous people
yeah is not only a virtual is not
necessary the first point is very
important presencia because interact
with the person question and details on
protest after positives a whole the
knowledge with the liquid education in
these in these items about the health
and education
ok